the hyper Avengers infinity war is
reaching boiling points and Kevin Feige
has now confirmed that are going to be
real character deaths in the movie
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to explain
why I think one specific superhero that
hasn't typically appeared on everyone's
death lists will be killed by Thanos in
the film I'm also starting a new Marvel
giveaway to enter make sure you're a
subscriber and tell me in the comments
who you think won't make it out of
infinity war alive and I'll announce the
winner of my last giveaway later in this
video
obviously speculation and potential
spoilers ahead for infinity war this
generally thought that Marvel are going
to hit fans big in Avengers infinity war
and kill off someone like cap or Ironman
after all Tony did have that vision in
age of Ultron amidst fellow heroes
strewn lifeless on a rock in outer space
but a recent II W interview with Josh
Brolin who plays fan ass has got me
thinking that it won't be a main eventer
we lose an infinity war when Brolin was
asked about balises daughter's nebula
and Gamora the actor found it difficult
to discuss although he did say the mad
Titan treats both Gamora and nebula as
tools for his own gain when pushed on
whether Thanos is cold the whole way
through or if he feels any affection for
them this is what Brolin said yeah I do
think he does when you see the
relationship with Gamora and you see
that evolves god I wish I could tell you
I can't obviously he has a grand plan
like somebody who's pulling in kids for
their own selfish bloodshed but he has a
capacity to love very much and very
deeply now I think it's very interesting
that Brolin specifically mentioned
Gamora but tried to stop himself from
revealing anything further in terms of
bigger plot points we need to remember
that Gomorrah is Thanos his favorite
daughter
and that favoritism has been something
that's been very painful for her
adoptive sister nebula demeanors that
have a pouty child and apparently
we're lien ated my favorite daughter so
why would the nose kill Gomorrah
well there's rumors that if Thanos does
get to all six Infinity stones he'll
still need something extra to be able to
use the soul stone that particular
infinity stone still hasn't been
revealed in the MCU that I've talked
about possible locations where it could
appear in my soul stone video but the
idea is that to be able to use the soul
stone II have to sacrifice someone you
love Thanos has a twisted love for his
daughters and Gamora is his favorite
which could mean that sanyaas will kill
her in order to control the soul stone
but before you get too upset just
remember we're talking comic book movies
here and it's quite likely that the
infinity war sequel will involve the
Avengers trying to reverse some of the
events from infinity war perhaps with
time travel as the Marvel killing Gamora
would indeed give their film and
emotional hit without there having to
retire one of the original core
characters like Iron Man or cap at this
point and there's actually a bit of
supporting evidence for this idea in the
form of one of the infinity war LEGO
sets for the final battle in which
Ironman Gomorrah and star-lord face off
against Thanos who's wielding an
infinity sword we don't know how this
battle will go but it could be the
moment in which Thanos carries out his
dastardly deed after all we do see Iron
Man extremely upset in this shot from
the first trailer and it looks like it
could be set on Thanos's homeworld Titan
we also know that in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 no killer came to term to
their sister Gamora and seeing thallus
kill her would be the final straw
setting up a huge revenge story for her
and Avengers 4 there are little girls
like you across the universe who are in
danger you can stay with us and help
them I will help them by killing that
you will always be my sister now I
really like Gomorrah so I'll be pretty
devastated if this does play out
however zoe saldana has already revealed
she's been filming on Avengers 4 but she
could have been filming flashback scenes
from before her death or if that movie
really does reverse some of the events
when finishing war then of course he
might see Gamora come back to life the
really interesting thing in all this is
that gomorrah's death would actually
parallel something which happened to her
in the comics when Gamora discovered
Tanis his master plan to kill off off
the universe she attempted to kill him
with a dagger
however Thanos mortally wounded her and
left her for dead
Adam warlock found Gamora about to die
and to save her he absorbed her spirit
into the soul gem and took her into a
place inside the gem called soul world
Gamora stayed in Soul world until the
events of the Infinity Gauntlet when
Adam warlock restored Gamora into the
real world via the body of a recently
deceased human she died again though
when Thanos erased half the universe
from existence by the way James Gunn has
said we won't be getting Adam warlock in
the Infinity war movie however he'll
likely appear in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 and I talked about how that will
happen in my Adam warlock teaser video
nebula also plays a key part in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and the file
defeat of Thanos initially in the
Infinity Gauntlet comics Salas wreaks
havoc on nebulas body torturing her and
turning her into a living corpse who he
uses to try and impress mistress death
later in the story though it's nebula
who turns the balance of power away from
Thanos by taking the gauntlet from him
nebula then restores the half of the
universe which Salazar killed which also
brings back Gamora
now I don't think this is exactly what
will happen in the movies however in
this glimpse of nebula from the Super
Bowl TV spot we can see that she's
absolutely furious at something
could it be she's just witnessed Thanos
appear to kill her sister Gamora
if nebula or another character does
reverse gomorrah's death or any other
effects of thanasis devastation that
would happen in Avengers 4 not infinity
war of course by the way another
possibility is that Marvel might do a
twist on this idea in the Infinity war
movie with Thanos killing nebula as she
goes up against him
rather than Gamora nebula is still one
of his daughters and so could be used by
Thanos to harness the power of the soul
stone with Gamora than having to exact
revenge on the mad Titan either way if
Gamora or nebula does die perhaps by
having their Souls taken from them by
Thanos then this would be quite an
emotional setup for Avengers 4 so do you
think Maura or nebula will be a casualty
in Avengers infinity war or do you have
any theories on who else anise might
kill and which character would you be
most upset to lose in the movie let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and subscribe for my new Marvel giveaway
the winner of my Jessica Jones giveaway
is on screen now if that's you private
message me with your details so I can
get your prize sent out to you and while
we all wait for the next infinity war
trailer check out my recent Avengers
videos and other Marvel theories by
tapping the screen here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers